[Musique]
non d' chien qu'est-ce qu' te prend tu
es malade ça va tu maîtrises pas d'accès
de colère incontrôlable non juste une
colère normale et légitime tu reprends
bien l'aspect de J pendant ton sommeil
c'était indispensable la C de brume
désolé j'ai pas pu résister il va te
falloir plusieurs années pour apprendre
à maîtriser tout ce que ça
implique yes c'est qui ton meilleur ami
l' l'élastan c'est l'élastan ton
meilleur ami être un Hulk exige un
certain sens de
l'équilibre tu as encore tellement à
apprendre bon tu vois bien que j'ai
réussi tous les
tests écoute si tu veux retourner à ta
vie d'avocade je respecte ton choix il
le pense pas
[Musique]
de plus en plus de superhumains
apparaissent un peu
partout nous avons créé un service
spécialement pour eux et je veux que
Miss Hul en soit la représentante
j
namast j'ai un sérieux conflit d'intérêt
cet homme a tenté de tuer mon cousin Bru
oui je connais
l'affaire les gens s'intéressent à moi
uniquement parce que je représente ile
blansski non il s'intéressent vraiment à
toi parce qu'il disent wou le cette
fille allez fais ton truc c'est pas vrai
je l' mets tellement
[Musique]
Stur j'en suis pas très
fier mademoiselle Walters nous répondons
à un plus grand pouvoir notre univers
est au bord du
précipice je suis avocate je dois
conformé au livre au livre des Vany non
au livre de droit américain à la loi
quoi que ça te plaise ou non tu es
désormais une superhéroïne c'est quand
vous
voulez vous vous souvenez de la copine
que vous aviez au
lycée celle qui était bien plus cool que
vous super canon celle qui attiré tous
les
regards salut je crois que je suis
jaloux c'est ça que je ressemble la JAL
[Musique]
attends attends bouge pas qu'est-ce que
tu fais de toutes ces conneries ça
m'aide à passer le
temps encore une nuit de
violence certaines personnes n'hésitent
pas à dire que d'ici très peu de temps
la ville va
exploser bon ça y est vous avez votre
compte alors
barrez-vous je l'ai trouvé le
Samaritain le Samaritain est mort depuis
25 ans ouais c'est ce qu'on
dit tu penses que tu habites en face
d'un super-héros va donc faire une
thérapie
écoute samarittin est
mort moi je récupère je répare des vieux
trucs pour vivre le Samaritain nettoie
les rues occupe-toi de tes affaires moi
je m'occupe des miennes je vous crois
pas du
tout ça va monsieur en pleine
forme vous êtes toujours aussi
fort non pas aussi fort qu'avant le
corps finit par se barrer si en prends
pas soin et j'en prends plus soin depuis
très
longtemps pourquoi vous vous
détestez parce que pour certains il est
trop tard pour réparer les dégâts qu'ils
ont
fait il cach quelque chose je veux qu'il
meure tu
rigoles les choses qu'on enterre
viennent vous hanter pourquoi vous avez
disparu e vieux
petit cadeau viens
[Musique]
là je s'appelle Grot
je s'appelle
[Musique]
gûte je s'appelle
groot je s'appelle
Grot
je s'appelle
[Musique]
gr maman c'est s' dit qu'il vit papait
plein de
bisous la famille alors laissezous
message on Rapp j'en ai Mar tu m'invites
je suis seule s'il te
plaît
Marie quoi vous êtes perdu je peux vous
conduire si vous
voulez ah ouais bonjour
l'ambiance et toutes les nuits le fils
il est sur sa barque cherche s son père
qui s
[Musique]
Noy dore fils à je Martin un grand gars
rappelez pas c'est parce queêtes pas
souvent je dérange vous cherchez quelque
chose vous avez pas vu mon
fils des émotions extraordinaires c'est
ça c'est peut-être ça vraimentarrête
avec tes mensonges et tu nous dis où tu
vas je veux pas être avec vous tout le
temps vous comprenez
ça Martin bébé c'était un ange et puis
très vite il est devenu cruel il s'est
mis à me torturer
Martin tu me connais
pas personne n'avait jamais suivi fallit
[Musique]
dingue happened it's been a really tough
year are you as happy as you made
[Musique]
me who is this and why the hell are you
calling to make sure you're
home cross MR and Mr
do you know why here I know your
history it's just
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
a when do we get to start stabbing
people no matter what he's going to come
for us
again hate that
doll ephany
to get what's coming
to
glenenda come to
Mama let go dear sweet godmother of Hell
Mar Jesus
[Musique]
this hi I'm Chucky Wan
pray
ve s
danst pour les
stageable non j'ai pas le tableau j'ai
quelquun une description m
95 et une petite fille de 4 ans il est
parti c'est elle qui l'a
[Musique]
quitté je la rencontrer je rencontrer
les là révident tu
sais enfant des autres
par bonjour quel âge 4 ans et demi
W
tu te faire un petit bisou voir mon cœur
oui bonjour Alice moi je suis
Rachel bonjour Rachel alors oui les
bisous les bonjours à Rachel pourquoi
rachel est tout le temps là moi je veux
qu'elle s'en
aille mais si tu crois un jour que tu 5
ans pas t'apprendre qu'à cage là ça veut
absolument rien dire dir que tu fais
simpement de pas comprendre que je
m'attache à elle à la fin de la journée
c'est vous son père et sa mère pour
toujours je resterai une figurante tu
[Musique]
exagères je me sens piégé moi aussi je
suis piégé tu vas encore des enfants pas
de problème c'est quand tu veux toi des
PI de quoi toi pour moi c'est trop
[Musique]
tard si vous voulez un enfant c'est
maintenant
oui on verra la vie est courte et longue
oui la viille est
longue on se dépêche on se dépêche et
pourquoi vous partez de semaines dans le
meilleur camp de vacances du monde parce
qu'il y a une célébrité secrète oh moi
je pensais à un truc comme parce qu'on
s'adore tous ou un truc un peu un peu
wcat bienvenue mes amis vous devez me
donner vos téléphones votre nourriture
et vos appareis connectés c'est que de
semaines mais ça Sacha ne le sait pas
Sacha et ton téléphone
cette année le camp show Lake a été
choisi pour une opportunité très
spéciale et tout de suite pour vous en
dire plus
monsieur ici sera réalisé la toute
première production de la Reine des
[Applaudissements]
Neiges on va passer le meilleur des
ét c'est mon prier est-ce qu'on sépare
dans la chambre est-ce qu'on reste en
groupe prier petit je viens de rendrete
que vousz passer tout l'été ensem prère
fois que je peux vraiment espérer
décrocher le premier r le temps est venu
de vous présenter votre metteur en
scène
Casel je crois que je flippe remue tes
plus beaux à tout
casuel tout ce qui retient mon attention
ce sont les auditions pour le moment
c'est quoi le nom des deux gars
principaux dans la Reine des Neiges de
c'est je dirais que c'est Gary aucun
d'ux ne s'appelle Gary cette fois tu
pourras pas te la jouer à la
ce que je peux t'assurer c'est que le
meilleur est à
[Musique]
venir ça va les j'ai l'impression que
ces dernières années m'ont aidé à me
préparer pour un super
truc personne ne pourra gâcher notre
parfaite été à T les
[Musique]
de nont jamais été aussi haut et je vais
le dire les enjeux n'ont jamais été
aussi
[Musique]
haut on porte un toast je déteste les
anniversaires ça je sais
[Musique]
souffle je veux faire une bande dessinée
de super-héros et en quoi est-ce qu'ils
sont si spéciaux en couple les
super-héros des temps modernes comme
nous tous je suis divorcé
assez parler de cette histoire des deux
moitiés de la pomme on rencontre l'homme
ou la femme de sa vie par pure
coincid les chanono cette
foiscij me grand salon de chambres il
est pas
question tu'es JIS au MO une fois dans
ta vie lancei sans vraiment réfléchir et
avoir ce sentiment P de liberté la
longéité de coupl
bien a quasiment arrêté de
parler peut-être que ça arrive parce
qu'on se dit plus la vérité tu as
continué à occuper une grande place dans
mon cœur vous vous
êtreevu selon vous seul un couple de
super-héros est capable de survivre à
l'amour pas à l'amour non mais autants
qui passe
oui je me disais que j'aimerais passer
ma vie entière avec
toi c'est faux que tout est déterminé
tout comme c'est faux que tout peut-être
prédit rien n'est
certain j'aimerais juste que ce moment
dure un peu plus longtemps ce moment est
le
nôtre il durera aussi longtemps qu'on le
fera
durer